what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and it looks like we could be seeing
some pretty big changes coming from
Marvel Studios if you haven't somehow
heard Disney has fired their CEO Bob
chapek and in doing so they actually
brought back the former CEO before Bob
chapek Bob Iger they decided to do this
because the board of directors and the
shareholders weren't very pleased with
the direction that Disney was going and
they weren't very pleased with the
performances of some things like Disney
plus so we knew with this announcement
and Bob Iger coming back that there
would probably be some changes to Marvel
Studios at least a little bit and it
seems like we were right According to
some sources which we'll dive into in a
bit Marvel is a little bit unhappy with
how phase 4 turned out and I'm sure some
fans can relate here I've heard many
different opinions over the course of
phase four and especially now that it's
ended I've heard it all from I hate it
to I loved it it's just kind of meh no
one's wrong no one's right everybody's
entitled to their own opinions how ever
this was truly a different phase for
Marvel Studios with the involvement and
the inclusion of Disney plus Marvel
Studios was completely changed and some
of it probably wasn't by choice with the
announcement of Disney plus and Marvel
Studios now making shows I'm sure Kevin
feige was excited about making some
shows however rumor has it and this is
just a rumor but rumor has it that Bob
chapek was having them pump out a lot of
content on Disney plus to get the
subscribers up for Disney plus this
would probably explain why Marvel
Studios over phase 4 felt like it was
more quantity over quality and
apparently that's how Bob Iger sees it
and there are about to be some pretty
big changes coming to Marvel Studios and
Disney plus this could impact Phase 5
but it could really impact phase six
because apparently right now Marvel
Studios is taking preventative measures
to assure quality control moving forward
with Phase 5 and phase six and simply
the future now today's report is coming
from some inside sources over at Marvel
and Disney from thecosmiccircus.com now
I'm going to read some of this article
and I want you all to really listen to
it and tell me what you think about it I
am genuinely curious to hear everybody's
reaction to it it starts off by stating
Marvel Studios and the problem with over
saturation Marvel's success back when it
was developing and rolling out the
infinity Saga was partly due to the way
Marvel paced itself with its releases in
a span of 11 years they released 23
films that explored the MCU with the
infinity Saga but in comparison phase 4
has had 19 projects alone one after
another over the span of two years eight
Disney plus series seven theatrical
releases and two Disney plus specials
and of course the Legends and I am Groot
shorts this great overflow of projects
then branches out as a series of other
issues with how Marvel has handled phase
four first and foremost a significant
part of the audience feels there is an
oversaturation of Marvel currently not
having a rest period between projects
makes it hard for fans to keep up with
The Saga and interest in future projects
begins to grow stale this is likely due
to not allowing fans to Garner enough
anticipation towards the next upcoming
project so here I truly want to know
from you do you think Marvel has put out
too much I have personally heard a lot
of fans tell me in live streams that
they're not excited for upcoming Marvel
projects and they are skipping on some
projects do you think this is partially
due to the fact that Marvel Studios is
releasing so many projects right after
another and of course there is also an
issue of quality having too many
projects released at one spreads
production Workforce thin we've heard a
lot about these rumors about Marvel
employees and Disney employees have been
working way over time and not really
getting compensated too well for it
they're basically overworked because
they have to do 19 Marvel projects in
the course of two years and now we have
many more coming as well of course this
leads to quality issues so Marvel and
Disney are they going to do something
about it well it sounds like they are
moving forward with Phase 5 and in phase
six the cosmic circus states that they
have received a word from their sources
that Marvel Studios is currently
re-evaluating its release lineup for
Phase 5 and 6. as phase four comes to a
close they've been informed of internal
negative feedback about how phase 4 was
handled regarding product distribution
and quality now I love Marvel obviously
you all know that but even I can admit
that sometimes the quality just wasn't
there and I'm not just talking about CGI
but I'm also talking about writing
sometimes I felt like the writing just
could have been better but now that
Marvel is reevaluating it actually kind
of gives me some relief not because I
think that they were doing too much or
that phase four sucked but simply due to
the fact that I think it's good that
Marvel Studios is listening to feedback
now of course we have to talk about the
big issue what does this exactly mean
for phase five and phase six if they're
not going to put out so much content how
does that affect the release schedule
and of course everybody's wondering now
is Phase 5 and phase six going to
essentially be delayed because they're
going to spread out these projects over
a longer period of time now there's good
news and there's bad news that comes
with this the good news is the sources
have stated projects already in
post-production are still set for
release at this time and the main focus
of the reevaluation will be on Project
still in pre-production stage this means
that most of Phase 5 is probably going
to be okay but there is a possibility
that the latter half of Phase 5 could
get pushed back a little bit and the bad
news is phase six is definitely up for
some reevaluation here is something that
the cosmic circus has been told they
said sources say to expect shifts in
release schedules for some projects
changes in media formats for others and
in the most extreme but unlikely and
this is the good news postponement or
outright cancellation of a project that
would not be suited towards the overall
story of the Multiverse Saga so that
right there that's the good news it says
that it's very unlikely that we'll see
any cancellation of any movie or show or
special however what is really
interesting is that they mentioned
changes in media formats for others
changes in media formats means a movie
shifting to a Disney Plus show a Disney
Plus show shifting to a movie or perhaps
a Disney Plus show shifting to a special
presentation which I actually think is a
pretty good idea I'm also for and Marvel
if you're listening I think a lot of
fans are too Marvel Studios releasing
shows all at once rather than releasing
new episodes each week I know She-Hulk
has very very mixed opinions but I think
personally that She-Hulk would have been
enjoyed much more if we could have
binged it to me it just wasn't a show
that you got excited for and anticipated
each week and each week a lot of fans
were let down and not looking forward to
the next episodes but I feel if we could
have binged it it would have been a
little bit more enjoyable and for those
who feel like they wasted their time
waiting week after week for the series
to get good in their opinion I feel like
you'd feel less like your time was
wasted if you could watch it all at once
but it has also been noted that the idea
of special presentations has gained
gained a lot more traction over at
Marvel Studios so if I had to guess I
think some Disney Plus shows will most
likely be turned into special
presentations and when it comes to
introducing new characters I actually
think special presentations in a lot of
cases would be the way to go I think it
was great for werewolf by night I think
the holiday special for Guardians of the
Galaxy was really great although no main
characters were introduced we were
introduced to Cosmo the dog but there's
rumors that a Nova project and a Silver
Surfer project could be coming in the
form of a special presentation and I
think introducing Nova in a special
presentation and then the Silver Surfer
in another would be a really good idea
then you can have them be in other
movies or give them their own movie but
special presentations will most likely
be 40 minutes to about an hour long each
time which is well enough time to
introduce a new character and tell a
story so hopefully if we do see some
drastic changes we'll only see Disney
Plus shows turned into special
presentations or movies they've already
turned armor Wars from a Disney Plus
show into a movie so that'll most likely
be the route they go but fingers crossed
they don't actually cancel or delay
anything too much but please leave your
comments down below and let me know your
thoughts do you think Marvel Studio
should slow down and focus on quality
over quantity or do you think they've
been okay so far let me know in the
comments down below please don't forget
to like the video and subscribe so you
can stay up to date on all things
relating to the MCU for live updates you
can follow us on Instagram and Twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof
[Music]